[Music]
Radio Flyer founded in 1917 is the
chicago-based manufacturer of tricycles
scooters and most classically little red
wagons Tesla Motors incorporated in 2003
is the Silicon Valley automaker leading
the innovation of electric cars put them
together and what do you get the Tesla
Model S for kids a battery powered ride
on toys for kids between ages three and
eight which brings us to our test
remember my name is Felix and in five
years old
Brooklyn New York one recent Saturday I
led the lad over to Brooklyn Bridge Park
it's a little less than a mile down the
road from the local test showroom and
seems like a great spot to put the car
through its paces assembly was quick and
the operations so intuitive that I could
condense a driver's ed class down to a
minute the toys two modes drive in
Reverse one pedal to accelerate and it
sports sideview mirrors a lithium ion
battery and headlights much like its
full-scale counterparts it also has an
auxiliary port and speakers cruising
with some tunes
the real Model S goes from 0 to 60 miles
per hour in two and a half seconds in
about the same span of time this one
went from zero to six it's top speed it
can also be set to a lower maximum speed
with three miles per hour by accessing a
child-resistant switch at the rear the
kids seem to be enjoying himself
that's what I'd expected he's one of
those kids thrilled just to sit in the
front seat of a parked rental car intend
to drive
the toy also proved to be educational
quickly broke the boy of the habit
oversteering
that is led to so many crashes in arcade
racing games so what about the bottom
line the vehicles based prize is $500
which maybe sounds like a lot of money
and to consider that in this
neighborhood that buys you about 20
hours of baby's life at first I'll Felix
had to say was it was fun then we've
been out for a cup of hot cocoa he took
out his colored pencils and drew me a
picture
the young man's self-portrait as
motorists told me that is Tesla ride
left the truly lasting impression
[Music]